it's been well over a year since apple
released the m1 mac mini and at this
point i can safely say that it's hands
down the best bank for the buck desktop
pc that you can get right now with sale
prices all the way down to hundred and
fifty dollars new or even five hundred
and fifty dollars with a renewed
guarantee from amazon and when i talk
about best bang for your buck i'm not
only talking about the impressive
performance of the m1 chip compared to
the competition but also things like
completely silent operation the compact
and portable design and lastly the
reliability of mac os which is by far
the most important thing for regular
consumers who just want their pc to work
and the beauty of the m1 mac mini is
that it's the absolute least expensive
way to get your hands on apple's famous
m1 chip especially if you're looking for
a desktop setup with more ports and
external devices like a large display or
external ssd storage connected to it and
if that sounds like something you'd
prefer over having an m1 macbook air
then the m1 mac mini is a no brainer but
the real issue i want to cover in this
review is whether you should buy one
right now or wait for the new redesigned
mac minis to come out and yes i said mac
minis since mark german believes both a
new low end and a high-end model are
coming this year but before i get into
explaining the differences between those
two new mac mini models let me first
talk about our experience with the m1
mac mini after over a year as you
probably already know apple simply took
the m1 chip and plopped it into the mac
mini without really changing anything
else and the most impressive part is
just how little room the actual m1 logic
board and cooling system takes up within
the chassis making it pretty obvious
that the future m2 mac midi redesign can
get a lot smaller but one of the
downsides to the m1 mac mini is the fact
that apple limited it to just two
thunderbolt ports instead of four on the
intel model and it kind of sucks that
the two usb-a ports are also limited to
just five gigabits per second speeds but
over the past year companies have been
coming up with some awesome solutions to
this port issue like for example treblet
who sent us over some hubs specifically
designed for the m1 mac mini and what
really makes these special is that they
match the color and the size of the mac
mini so you can simply stack it on top
and the best part of all is that all the
usb ports are twice as fast as the ones
on the back of the mac mini supporting
full 10 gigabit per second speeds as
well as giving you sd card and cf
express slots but my favorite part of
all is that they come with a built-in
nvme ssd slot rated at full 2 800
megabytes per second speeds so you're
getting a secret external ssd without
using any extra desk space and you can
easily daisy chain multiple hubs stacked
on top of each other for even more ports
and ssd connections but if you're
looking for something even more compact
in case you're an m1 macbook user
they've also got a new usb4 super dock
complete with extra ports like
thunderbolt displayport ethernet full
speed usb ports and of course an
internal 2800 megabytes per second nvme
ssd slot making for the smallest and
fastest dock on the market right now
that also supports 60 watt macbook
charging so if you never want to worry
about ports again you can find the links
to both of these trebley products down
in the description below now moving on
to the actual performance of the m1 mac
mini we noticed that the m1 chip was
extremely impressive in terms of cpu
performance and cinebench r23 compared
to the old intel i7 model but the thing
that shocked us the most was that the m1
was completely silent during the test
with the fans running at the idle 1700
rpm compared to 4 400 rpm on the intel
mac mini not only that but it was using
much less power only around 13 watts
compared to a steady 75 on the intel i7
but the absolute biggest difference was
graphics performance with the m1 being
over four times faster than the
integrated intel graphics which was
mind-blowing but in real world gaming
benchmarks there was an even bigger
difference now almost six times faster
and then when we got to all the real
world tests the m1 continued to
slaughter the i7 and everything from
music production lightroom photo editing
xcode programming and especially video
editing and final cut pro where the
differences were absolutely crazy so
based on all of that it's pretty obvious
that apple made the right choice by
switching over to their new m1 chip but
over the past year the difference that
really stood out is that it just runs so
much more reliably it's basically always
snappy compared to the occasional hang
ups that the intel chips would have and
the instant on feature that craig
federighi showed off is a life changer
that you could only realize when you go
back to an intel based system and trust
me that is no joke because max still
uses our fifteen thousand dollar intel
mac pro setup in the office every day
because we still haven't been able to
sell it ever since the m1 launched and
the one thing he always complains about
is how the mac pro
isn't nearly as snappy as a 1 000
m1 macbook air i literally just asked
him to run a web browsing speed test and
his mac pro came back with 46.6 points
for some weird reason instead of the
usual 134 when everything is running
perfectly compared to a massive
281 points with the m1 mac mini so the
point that i'm making is that apple has
optimized this chip incredibly well so
that it simply runs great all the time
compared to occasional hiccups with
intel chips that makes you want to
restart the machine to get refreshed
performance and this level of everyday
reliability is what makes the m1 chip
truly special now the even crazier thing
is that our main editor angelica has
been using the 24 inch m1 imac for the
past nine months to edit almost every
single video that goes up on our channel
and she literally does not remember the
last time she's heard any fan noise at
all even while exporting our 4k videos
and the stories exactly the same for the
m1 mac mini and it's simply mind blowing
that you can now buy one for as low as
650 dollars brand new or 550 renewed
with this level of performance and
reliability during a time when windows
desktop pc prices are sky high because
of graphics chip shortages and
everything else so if you're someone who
just wants a reliable desktop computer
for everyday use the m1 mac mini is
literally the best bang for the buck pc
out there and it's an absolute
no-brainer but the only downside of the
m1 mac mini is that performance is
limited for those who really need a lot
of power for productivity work seeing as
the latest alder lake i5 12600 12600k
cpu for around 280 on amazon is now
quite a bit faster in terms of
performance and while a full custom
built desktop pc with this new intel cpu
will be a lot more expensive than the m1
mac mini there's no doubt that the m1
chip simply isn't enough for the heavy
power users out there and if that's you
i would say that you should 100 wait for
apple's redesigned mac mini models that
are rumored to be coming as soon as next
month's march 8th event which is when
i'm personally expecting apple to reveal
the new high-end m1 max mac mini
complete with the first full redesign in
almost 12 years and if you're wondering
what it's going to look like renders by
shylesh recently made some new renders
showing off just how impressively thin
it's going to look compared to the
current model and yes it's going to come
with four thunderbolt ports and the new
magnetic power connector from the m1
imac but the most important part of all
is that you'll be able to configure it
with up to the crazy m1 max chip with 64
gigs of ram and the 32 core gpu which
has more than enough performance for
almost everyone out there now the only
caveat is that i'm personally expecting
it to start at thirteen hundred dollars
for the base m1 pro model but if you
care about performance whatsoever i
would definitely wait for the new
redesigned high-end mac mini model but
in the case that you're not looking to
spend that much money there's also a
good chance that apple will be updating
this m1 mac mini later this year with
the m2 chip for around the same price or
maybe a hundred dollars more brand new
which will be awesome because of the new
redesign so in my opinion if you can
wait until potentially october i would
probably do that for the new design
alone but if you want a reliable budget
pc right now for as low as 550 renewed
on amazon you can find a link to that
deal in the description below because
that's the best option right now so
hopefully you enjoyed this one year
review of the m1 mac mini and if you did
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out the redesigned
mac made leaks video right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]